على مدار 30 عامًا ، جمع سوق السفر العربي بين
المتخصصين في مجال السفر من جميع أنحاء العالم
لمناقشة الاتجاهات والابتكار في الصناعة ، وقد
استضاف الحدث 7000 زائر في
عامه الأول
سريعًا إلى الأمام حتى عام 2022 ، وقد اجتذب أكثر
من ثلاثة أضعاف هذا الرقم ، إنه مجرد
مثال واحد  من النمو الذي شهده
قطاع السياحة في المنطقة
في العقود الماضية ،
شهد الشرق الأوسط افتتاح برج
العرب الأيقوني في دبي مركز المملكة في
المملكة العربية السعودية أبو ظبي مسجد الشيخ زايد
الكبير متحف الفن الإسلامي
في قطر وعالم البحرين  المركز التجاري
برج خليفة في دبي
والمتحف الوطني لسلطنة عمان ومبنى إسرائيل
في السعودية
تضاعف عدد الوافدين الدوليين إلى المنطقة تقريبًا بين عامي 2004
و 2019. إنها منطقة
يعتمد اقتصادها إلى حد كبير على النفط وقد
رأينا ذلك  لقد حددت الوجهات منذ فترة طويلة
السياحة كأحد
أولوياتها وأحد أولوياتها
في تنويع اقتصادها ، رأينا
أنه من حيث الاستثمار في
البنية التحتية في السعة الجوية في
تطوير منتجات تسويقية قوية ،
ووضع قوي
ثم جاء وباء كوفيد -19  نظرًا
لانخفاض أعداد السفر بشكل كبير في
جميع أنحاء العالم ، تستعد البلدان في المنطقة
للتخفيف من التأثير على السياحة ،
ما حدث في الشرق الأوسط
أولاً وقبل كل شيء رأينا انتعاشًا سابقًا
مع فتح العديد من الوجهات أيضًا في وقت
مبكر لتسهيل الدخول في وقت مبكر
وأعتقد أن أحد الأمثلة الجيدة على ذلك هو  من المحتمل أن
الإمارات التي
ظهرت في عام 2022 من حيث الدخل الناتج عن السياحة ،
تقول منظمة السياحة العالمية التابعة للأمم المتحدة ، إن
المنطقة شهدت انتعاشًا ، حيث
استعادت وجهات الشرق الأوسط
حوالي 90 من إجمالي عدد
زوارها المشمولين مسبقًا ، وهو حقًا
مستوى مذهل إذا  تقارن العالم
بأنها أفضل منطقة أداء مرة أخرى
ونرى في الواقع أول
منطقة تحقق ربعًا كاملاً من
النتائج الإيجابية مقارنة بما كانت عليه في فترة ما
قبل الجائحة